you quoted jordan peterson was just here
friday
um sitting your seat right there and
basically i've seen him say saying women
want to date
horizontally or vertically meaningly
like your same status or above where men
is just like
i'll take it from women like a three to
a ten i don't give a women have uh
women have attraction floors men do not
have attraction floors and whatever
break that down yeah well let's just i
mean let's put it in nuts and bolts here
is if you've got a guy who is like a six
he'll date a woman who he would love to
get with a woman who's a nine but no
one's ugly after two a.m right so we
have a much we have
we have a much broader um
much broader scope when it comes to you
know the women that we're willing to get
with either as mating opportunities or
as like say a relationship our stand
like men today are simply not even
allowed to have standards so when we
talk about like well you what do you
look for in a woman most guys is like
well you know she was there and it just
seemed like it was the right thing to do
for women if a woman is a six she's
looking for a guy who's a six or above
and if that guy is a six she's looking
for that guy she the guy who's the seven
might be somebody that she wants to get
with it's uh it's not necessarily a sort
of mating but it is looking for the next
the bigger and the better deal and does
that mean now because people are going
to give me this um does that mean that
you know well if i get with a woman
she's always going to be looking for the
next big bigger better thing no because
hypergamy is not a straight jacket and
what i mean by that is as women mature
their ability to you know discern what's
my sexual market bill uh
the sexual market value versus his if
that woman is say a seven and he's a six
at 28 years old when they get married
and now they get to be in their 30s
their mid-30s and suddenly he's made
partner in the law firm he's made
maximize his potential he goes up in
sexual market value while she goes down
a notch that's what i'm talking about
maybe that's what solidifies that
relationship and it makes it a healthy
relationship
it's not necessarily like well oh i'm
doomed because women i why would i
bother getting with a woman who's just
gonna go look for the next best thing
it's not just about that there's a lot
of variables that go along so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you